hey cool Oscorp looked accurate again
even recreated the rooftop from the
first movie it's just in a completely
different part of the city now huh
continuity boom hey this is part 2 of
this review go check out the first one
if you haven't already there was so much
to sort through and I didn't want
everyone to wait three months for a new
video so this one's broken up in two
pieces which is topical since carnage is
in this game also I got a Twitter
account because people kept telling me
to get a Twitter account so send your
memes fanart and hate mail over there
okay thanks here's the review now now
let's get to the things that I do like
well spider-man has much better quips
when he's swinging around and even some
good ones when he's fighting people oh
you're not taking this seriously are you
really that slow the dialogue for him is
less cringy and thoughtless though it
still hit some rough patches
and they even kept one of my favorite
classic spider-man tropes he just kind
of talks to himself about things while
he's swinging it gives him time to
introspect and consider if it's really
worth it to switch cable providers
Craven can teach me his hunting
techniques not to rely on police
broadcast to find bad guys it's not like
I tell Craven my real names I'll be on
guard for any kind of double-cross where
he goes on long rants about how
unsuccessful his love life is they did a
decent job of ambulating these moments
in the game I like the lighting effect
for when he's in the shadow and all you
can see are his eyes I like that you can
go walk around in the comic shop and
talk to Stanley I mean it's weird that
he's a dedicated character to this
universe now but can anyone complain
about seeing this man in anything look
at him he's the guy everyone wishes was
their grandpa well enough said
anytime you need inspiration I'll be
right here ha ha ah he's so charming
another thing I appreciate is the
unlockable costumes I feel like that's
almost something that should be expected
from superhero games
modeling new costumes was too expensive
so they use the models from the last
three games to make up for it and those
honestly look way better than the main
suit this was the best on-screen costume
for the character at the time but the
version in the game looks so shoddy and
plastic the blue segments are way too
bright while the red is too dark it
looks awkward when doing animations and
his proportions just seemed off like his
neck is too thin I don't know if there
was one character model that absolutely
had to look right it would be this one
you'd be better off just wearing the one
from the last game which is weird
because this one looks better now
because the lighting effects are
different in this game or just be Spider
Man noir I apparently came off as
sounding like I don't like him in the
shattered Dimensions review but I think
he's awesome he's just extremely easy to
make jokes about which brings me to my
next point
it's time for my favorite segment of
these reviews something I think you'll
all recognize a whole bunch of stupid
[__]
your call spider-man chase us or let
those people burn chase us or let them
burn wait what what chase you or let
them burn that doesn't make any sense it
should be chase us and they'll all burn
or something the voice actor in the
booth should have at least brought it up
that this was a typo or sounded wrong
who the hell took this picture was it
him did he drop the camera while it was
set to automatic and this was the
resulting image before a shattered into
as many pieces as scorpions jaw oh no
don't wear any formal attire to this
party with a bunch of millionaires just
wear your ratty Charlie Day jacket and
basketball jersey no one will notice
why can't you hit him he's standing
still oh my god
oh hey they have to acknowledge the
Rhino suit thing yeah I can't exactly
dance around that Flo
I really want to know what circumstances
led to this guy getting under this train
in this way I feel like depending on his
location he'd either be able to crawl
out just fine or he'd be pinned with
thousands of pounds of force that should
have snapped him in a gravel or at the
very least spider-man removing the
weight of this train in such a swift
motion would suddenly depressurize his
body and cause him to burst into a sea
of crimson fluid spatter and forth
across the tracks of this unholy
railroad or maybe he was just picking up
a penny and his foot got stuck did I
mention I'm trying to publish a horror
novel why are there ads for spider-man
comics in the opening of the game before
spider-man even existed
Harry needs spider-man blood to cure his
disease saying that he's the only
healthy example of a cross species wait
but what about black cat Wilson Fisk
ordered scientists at Ravencroft to give
her powers and they succeeded why can't
Harry just have them help him out since
he's currently partnered with Fisk to
fund the crime task force well he says
Fisk is waiting him out so he could buy
Oscorp after he dies but who on earth
would want to do that
this company has a terrible reputation
and seems just like a black hole for
money because they spend all their
annual budget on stupid [__] like
Yeager's to fight non-existent kaiju
just let Harry live because he's like 19
and you could pretty much convince him
to do anything if you help them out a
little so you can still have oscorp's
resources and a business partner to help
keep up public appearance especially
when Ravencroft has the resources to do
these kinds of experimental procedures
more safely than Oscorp ever could in
fact that's just another reason why Fisk
should not want ODS Corp and if Fisk is
still trying to strong-arm him out of
the company Harry could just threaten to
blow the whistle on him and publicly say
Wilson Fisk is intentionally letting my
health decline so he can steal the
company after I die
they've never sell stock to him then and
that would at least get the ball rolling
for someone to investigate viscous
crimes if Harry just up and died one day
I mean at this point what is there to
lose right more serious than death
I'll take my chances now get out Harry
hey wait I figured out a solution for
your disease hey Harry you gotta listen
to me
Haylee Oh fine
be that way turn green and die you prick
we got to stop people from defusing this
bomb let's all stand around it in a
circle to keep people away okay here's
the most stupid [__] of all the stupid
[__]
the second story mission that closes out
the plot thread about Carradine is such
a mess that I feel like I really have to
point out how much of a problem it is
for the whole game
so spider-man sees this guy doing an
arms deal in broad daylight right next
to the street despite how large this
alley is and spider-man's first reaction
is to drop down really far away and wait
until the guy notices him instead of
just nabbing him right then and there
so Carradine makes him look like a total
Punk and runs away when suddenly some
other guy dressed like a thug from the
hood who just happens to be passing by
helps him hijack a car and they shove
the hostage into the passenger seat and
take off then spider-man catches up to
the car after some embarrassing
programming and the hostage is now in
the back seat because they only had one
animation built for getting her out of
there
the guy in the back then starts waving
around a machete to which spider-man
responds by killing him with severe
whiplash by tethering him to a building
with a short web line as he's ejected
from the car going 70 miles an hour
which he does all the time it's fine
then Peter gets the hostage to safety
while Carradine's brand plan comes to
fruition and makes a full circle around
the block stopping near the same alley
he just ran away from but for some
reason in all the hubbub Carradine rolls
the vehicle off the road causing it to
catch on fire he flees back into the
alley he just left with the guy who was
webbed up 1 minute and 35 seconds ago
being gone now now because Carradine's
all alone Cletus jumps out and stabs him
to death only like ten feet away from
this massive car accident that tons of
people saw he also has time to bury the
body under exactly 15 trash bags because
he understands that we need a t rating
regardless he signs his work in blood
men escapes to some location within a 40
foot radius where Peter spider-sense
could never possibly spot him
all this happened in like 18 [__]
seconds while spider-man turned a corner
to get back here this mission basically
sets up the plot for the whole game and
I want you to think about that because
clearly no one else did when they made
this game oh please play Oh find a man
why am I glad you're here listen the big
furry thing just came along here sat
right on my grape soda
I hadn't been off-duty why I'd have
arrested him for unlawful City Wow
Peters closet consists entirely of
assorted Spiderman costumes that he
leaves out in the open while he's out of
the house all day no wonder he only ever
wears one outfit gee I wonder if he's
spider-man yeah still not as bad as the
time Aunt May just flat out found the
suit and Peter said yeah it's just a
Halloween costume and she actually
bought that explanation after looking at
this one for a while I have to say I was
way too rough on the first amazing
spider-man game about its graphics that
game looks like Crysis compared to this
I'm not of the belief that graphics make
the game or anything but it certainly
helps you appreciate it more when the
characters don't look like abominations
that attended uncanny valley high school
together all the characters have such
derpy faces and plastic hair Harry
Osborn looks like an angry Ken doll and
he always has this look on his face like
he just smelled something really awful
Peter's lip sync is at from software
levels of not even trying Aunt May looks
like that I don't know just look at her
Jesus pretty much the only character in
the game that looks well modeled as
Kraven not even Peter looks that detail
then again the long drawn-out dialogue
segments are actually worth sitting
through to laugh at all the bugs
haha Jesus I hate this the odd jobs on
the side are a mess and weigh down the
entire game in terms of quality the
system in place for making these more
necessary to do than well not at all is
that spider-man's public image is
affected by whether he helps out or not
so if you do the side jobs the reporter
from the last game explains that
spider-man is awesome on the news and if
you screw up J jonah Jameson complains
about how terrible you are at the whole
responsibility thing I understand the
idea but a still image with recycled
dialogue playing over and over as well
as a meaningless karma meter don't
incentivize you to do jack [__] this bar
turning red only means more enemies show
up in the city to attack you but if you
go from story mission to story mission
quickly enough you won't even have to
worry about them it also doesn't help
that every single side mission is
awkwardly designed or broken the street
criminals aren't really even doing
anything except standing around looking
suspicious until you drop down awkwardly
and fight them don't be so quick to
judge spider-man I mean look at those
guys what if there were asbestos workers
and lost the keys to the building you uh
look like you need some help there you
know just keep at it buddy you almost
got it - any any second now that thing's
coming loose just just just keep if you
have you tried jimmying lock with like
you know yeah okay well I mean we could
do like the Jessica Jones thing I could
just break it off the lock almost there
the photo missions now consist of taking
pictures of police officers standing
around near laptops oh boy that's even
more interesting than the [__] bench
they really went the extra mile on that
one the missions where you fight gangs
that are holed up somewhere poorly laid
out and consistently glitchy she's it oh
my god oh oh oh my god didn't mean to
are you okay
and the worst of the worst are the
missions where you pull people from
burning buildings so seeing inside of a
burning building is hard enough already
but let's add a layer of difficulty
beyond that the spider scent / Detective
mode thing makes all texture disappear
from the walls so you're in a
silhouetted room and the only thing
visible is the fire I have to use this
to see where the civilians and
sprinklers are but at the cost of being
able to navigate this room in any
capacity to the point that it's worth it
to just skip all these missions to save
your sanity web zipping in and out of
the windows is a train wreck because the
detection on the perch point is all
[__] up and I'll spend half the time
crawling around on the wall while the
people inside start looking like my
preference of steak and the media gets a
helicopter view of the whole debacle
some poor soul that travel fourth floor
never made it out ah okay [__] it just
skip all these it's not worth it to get
a little blue progress bar to pat you on
the head for wasting time we're sticking
with the story missions so carnage being
the main antagonist of this game was
kind of bold and unique being that venom
wasn't even introduced yet and the movie
series was still looking like it had a
lot of ground to cover
I remember rumors that they would
attempt venom again and the amazing
spider-man 3 so I do feel like this game
is gun jumped on adapting the story
speaking of what was the plan for the
sequel of Gwen isn't here and her death
isn't even addressed I can't help but
think there's an alternate universe out
there where Sony hadn't jumped ship with
the franchise and B NOx had to make
amazing spider-man 3 a game where Peter
actively avoids mentioning Gwen's
existence at all costs because the
narrative is now disconnected to the
point of no return movie tie-in games
are tricky they have to represent what
they're based on without contradicting
or impeding on that material and both of
these games fail at that there's bombs
planted all across the city do you know
what that means I better head home then
it's dangerous out here someone with
training needs to handle this just
kidding
bombs underground and in a few minutes
no way am i letting anyone set off bombs
in my city have to find those bombs
uh-oh more hostages in a bomb have to be
really careful here they left a clue
that will help me track down those bombs
get to the bar they're trying the blogs
going out throughout downtown are bombs
have planted filled with a deadly gas
when they go off well use
this is bad they've planted bombs all
over the subway even in this room I have
to deal with the green Menace later I
can't let those bombs go off start the
timer on the bomb and take out all the
hostages that's that there's still at
least one bomb out there better track it
down listen these crazies have chained
our boss to a bomb up ahead the robbers
have been taken care of but what can I
do about the bomb think Spidey think
Wow disarming bombs so easy
nice try Hiro but our boss always has a
back-up plan he's planted bombs all over
the walls of the building no one can get
to them in time
this belongs
what kind of twisted freak plants bombs
on walls as a back-up plan
okay dynamite
no one plans bombs in my city no leave
it for the bomb squad yeah whatever
now on I am the bomb squad okay enough
fanservice back to the video the worst
part of the plot is that Cletus Kasady
becomes carnage from an Oscorp
experiment in his screen time can be
measured in a single boss fight this is
such a great character and using him
only for one fight feels almost
disrespectful his role in the story
before this doesn't really work for his
character and I thought really hard
about how this game could have been
improved replace carnage with Sin Eater
it's that simple now for those who don't
know the Sin Eater was a serial killer
who targeted public officials that were
corrupt and didn't fit in with his
notions of morality he ran around
blowing people away with a shotgun
because they were involved with blue
collar crime and they would have gotten
away with it if it weren't for his
actions he also became so mentally
unstable they killed police captain Jean
dewolff for reasons I won't spoil it's a
really great storyline and I highly
recommend these issues to check it out
this character would have been great to
fill the role of the controversial
serial killer that gets spider-man
questioning his own morals and I don't
know if they had the rights but Cravens
role would have been better if he had
been swapped out with the Punisher which
is more of what they tried to make him
into I think they could have done this
because kingpin is typically cited as a
daredevil villain but he first appeared
in spider-man whoa Punisher his first
appearance was in a spider-man book 2
and this isn't a movie so I'm sure they
could have gotten away with inserting
him in the game without stepping on any
toes at the MCU I mean it's too late now
because the Berlin wall keeping
spider-man out is gone but I still think
it's worth mentioning the story was
sadly just below what could have made it
the saving grace of this game overall
it's a game that is full of almost the
amazing spider-man 2 is a glitchy
nightmare
the gameplay ranges from being really
dull to being simply oak
at best and the story is just short of
being a good one I think that the most
difficult part about playing this is
that it's hard to figure out who the
blame was Activision just slowly
dismantling the franchise to focus on
other things and that's why everything
looks so cheap
or was the development team just
desperate to rush it out and move on to
the next one because it became so hard
to care when the budget cuts came I
guess in the end no one's really to
blame the situation just sucks it said
that things decayed so much over the
years that game changers like Spider Man
2 or masterpieces like ultimate and web
of shadows or even lesser-known but
still well told crossover games all led
to this attempt at the time Batman was
making his comeback and rising from a
career in shitty games and becoming the
new giant of the genre while the
original pioneer of superhero games fell
apart and was pretty much forgotten
there was a clear love of the character
behind this game or else they wouldn't
have put in so many small story nods or
character homage is like the comic shop
stands hartfeld advice all the comics
sprinkled throughout the game but that
doesn't excuse everything else for being
so underwhelming or downright broken I'd
have to say that I certainly don't
recommend this one 10 out of 10
too much Call of Duty
well I did it I reviewed all of them
excluding shitty ports of course but I
may get to those in time it's been just
under a year since I made the very first
part of this series I think we've all
had a few laughs we learned a lot more
about one of our favorite fictional
characters as well as the inherent
difficulty of portraying him correctly
in video games and most important of all
we came out of it with that bomb squad
joke with which many memes and t-shirts
will be created farewell my friends I'm
going to figure out what the hell I'll
review next oh wait I'll just let you
pick yes that's right you here's a
strawpoll what do we talk about now okay
I'll just all I'll wait here while you
go do it did you do it still loading the
page okay I'm still here you're checking
is all all right just uh click one of
those all right done okay
cool see you later
but wait there is more you didn't think
I'd close this thing off without
answering the question on everyone's
minds right what really was the best
spider-man game well the answer is a bit
more complicated than that because it
actually is spider-man 3 spider-man 3 is
the shining example of excellence among
a notion of garbage in the genre and
it's the perfect example of how
important it is to check your facts
before making a review ok yes I wasn't
doing the swinging right
you can jump at the end of your swing
despite my incompetence that still
didn't make this [__] go any
smoother I'll tell you that for free
anyway this is the paragon of virtue and
Batman wishes his games were this
well-crafted
just kidding it's a tie web of Shadows
and ultimate are the best examples of
what it takes to get the job done both
of them had solid and unique gameplay
interesting stories accurate portrayals
the character great cast of side
characters awesome mechanics that
haven't been replicated yet and best of
all they captured the heart of the
comics and how it should feel to have
the weight of the whole city on your red
and blue clad shoulders ultimate was
like seeing a comic play out on screen
with you at the helm of the youngest and
most badass version of spider-man from
PlayStation 2 era web of Shadows
presented a dark and epic tale that
explores the decision spider-man makes
to save the city and it shows what it's
like to be seduced by power whether you
realize it or not I was originally sort
of hard on this game for being darker
than usual but after reading stories
like Cravens last haunt or a child
within I now understand that
spider-man's story should be allowed
some variety when it comes to tone the
stuff he sees on a day-to-day basis
isn't always something to make jokes
about I really had to fight the urge to
be a biased jackass and just pick my
favourite ones for the best of the best
but objectively speaking the ones that I
like the most aren't the greatest so if
you won't get these ones too because
they're pretty damn good but this is the
silver metal category I'm sure I'll get
a lot of people saying spider-man 2 was
one of if not the absolute best but I
feel like that maybe nostalgia getting
in the way
I wanted to make sure that my love for
this game didn't cloud the fact that
there are some problems Tobey Maguire's
voice acting needed some work didn't
your mom tell you not to hit girls
the sidequest system was a little wonky
and needed some fine-tuning and the
final boss was a marketing ploy to raise
sales for replacement controllers after
so many mysteriously exploded against
the walls of our homes in 2004 it is
definitely a great game and I can't
count the amount of times I played it
but it just doesn't reach that threshold
it was the step in the right direction
to end all steps in the right direction
is it so more than anything we should
respect this game it put us on the path
to bigger and better things by daring to
have new ideas and show that you could
pull something truly amazing out of the
character for this medium this is the
archetype that so much of the genre is
built on top of and its innovations are
exceptional among [__] like in fact I'd
be as bold as to say it's not the best
spider-man game but it is one of the
absolute best superhero games I think
out of them all the very first one is my
undisputed favorite game the PlayStation
1 games are memorable and charming
comic-book fun that captures the essence
the character well yeah it's a little
cheesy in places but it's what made me
fall in love with the story and the
character and put me on the path to
getting here talking into a microphone
in a room by myself it's been awesome
finding my place on YouTube and hearing
from so many people who love this stuff
as much as I do all the comments from
people talking about their thoughts of
the games their favorite storylines
their recommendations for things to read
and watch it's been great getting to
express my feelings about these things
since a lot of these observations and
ideas have been in my head for years
with no way to get them across until now
and it's still a little strange to me
that series like this actually found
such a big audience thanks for watching
everyone
and thank you for not picking Ultimate
Alliance in that strawpoll because that
would take forever to add it you you
didn't right right Oh God
what's the matter Peter
you look like you lost your last friend
hey but I know for a fact you've still
got at least one Oh at all spider-man is
one of my all-time favorite comic
characters and he always has been but
capturing what he is in what he's
supposed to mean is no easy task and
every game gets at least something right
even the bad ones here's hoping that the
next one does even better than its
lineage he makes us all proud and even
if it's not as good as we're all hoping
for it'll be a step up from hitting rock
bottom and hey take it from me you are
one of those heroes so what do you say
are you gonna go out there and prove it
I want you to do it for Uncle Ben and
for me yeah yes Dan I will think after
so many years of waiting for something
to surprise us all again it's easy for
people to get jaded and start picking it
apart before it even releases where's
the fun in that
let's all sit back and just see how it
goes because really there's nowhere to
go but up no matter how much I might
wish things were different
there's only one spider
have more fun you're a superhero needle
swings in New York City gotten colored
tights my hubris my vanity cost rose in
your life
i'ma say
you can't keep others for me
I will do the girl from you the one the
only spire
accept no substitutes
it's not
new spider-man has given me alive and
taken a lot away with what thing never
changes my responsibility
no matter what the cost
gets to live happily
you don't get that I can't turn my back
on danger no matter what the cost and
you got no business calling yourself
spider-man
I prefer life
so I am
must be nice what knowing who you are
Eddie
I don't know let's get up
drugs
just our
I'm too dumb
all those died
be with you
we want sneezer want
now
I made a decision I know
I know the life I'm chosen
things are pretty good for our hero
you